let's have a look now at the latest
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
the italian government is easing travel
restrictions allowing people to move
freely
inside their home region as of monday
and between regions
starting june 3rd india has surpassed
china's tally of confirmed infections
with nearly 86 000 cases
russian health authorities say they have
registered an additional 9 200
coronavirus infections in the past
24 hours
moving on to brazil now where the new
health minister has
quit after less than a month on the job
his departure comes as the coronavirus
pandemic rages in the country
with hospitals overwhelmed in several
cities despite the spread of covet 19
brazil's far-right president jai
bolsonaro continues to downplay the
virus
and opposes lockdown measures
as brazil struggles to fight the
pandemic the country has become one of
the world's hot spots for covet 19
with a death toll now surpassing 800
people a day
so the health minister's resignation
could not come at a worse time
life is made of choices and today i
chose to leave
i can say that i gave the best of myself
the days that i was here
during this period it is not simple to
be in a ministry like this one during
such a difficult period
didn't give any reason for his decision
but it's been clear he disagreed with
president
bolsonaro's promotion of a controversial
anti-malaria drug
to fight covet-19 and his push to
re-open the economy
are people dying yes they are and i
regret that
but many more are going to die if the
economy continues to be restricted
[Applause]
a recent poll shows one-third of voters
still back the president
but more and more brazilians are unhappy
with how he is dealing with the pandemic
news of the health minister's
resignation prompted pot-banging
protests
in major cities
demonstrators accused bolsonaro of
recklessness
and failing to save lives
the number of india's confirmed
coronavirus cases has surpassed china's
climbing to nearly 86 000 infections
but so far the death rate in india
appears appears better
compared to china indian health
officials say
that could be because most people
infected were either asymptomatic
or had mild symptoms the country's swift
and fast shutdown is also credited with
preventing a worse outbreak the
government is set to decide on whether
to extend
india's nearly seven week lockdown
well for more on this now i'm joined by
uh india correspondent namisha jaiswal
from delhi namisha
the caseload is higher than in china now
does
this mean the country's likely to extend
lockdown measures
well rebecca looks like the opposite in
fact right now
india's third phase of its long lockdown
ends tomorrow on sunday and the prime
minister has indicated
that further easing is likely on monday
already over the last two weeks people
have been allowed to come out more
in private workers offices have started
off in some capacity
and it seems that the fourth phase
actually might bring some limited public
transport back on the roads
trains have already started running it
seems that the government seems
fairly confident despite the high case
load again perhaps indicating the low
death rate and the high recovery rate in
india
as the reason why it feels this way
now we're getting some early word from
the afp news agency
about the conditions in one of mumbai's
hospitals that they're
they're particularly devastating there
how is the indian health system coping
with this situation
that's right rebecca that actually is
the concerning matter given that easing
is happening
the government has reiterated that india
is ramping up infrastructure
and even increasing its ppe protect
production capacities
and we have capital new delhi saying
that open up
everything because they feel they are
have ramped up infrastructure enough
that they will be able
to handle a spike but then we have
reports like the mumbai hospital you
speak of
where they're saying mumbai has run out
of beds maharashtra the state mumbai is
in has over a third of india's cases
they're saying that body bags lying in
hospitals alongside patients
and this is of course very concerning
and we'll again have to wait to see
what exactly is actually going to be the
direction places like mumbai take
given how intense the outbreak is there
now the poor unsurprisingly have been
particularly hard hit especially migrant
workers
and we've seen lots of devastating cases
is help on the way
well rebecca the government has
announced a stimulus package which it
claims is 10
of india's gdp this is targeted at small
businesses farmers
and migrants there's going to be free
food grain distributed for example
but again and again we've seen
devastating visuals of an
exodus from india's urban centers of
rural migrants
the government has started up trains and
buses over the last couple of weeks but
people are still hanging on
by all means of transport to try to get
home just earlier today
24 migrants lost their lives in a road
accident over the last two weeks
there have been similar deaths reported
over 50 deaths across the country
so definitely the help that is on the
way needs to get to these people
more urgently and transport needs to be
arranged so that they can safely get
home
without infecting others but also make
it back to their loved ones
namisha jaiswal speaking to us from
delhi thanks very much